okay so I'm just finishing getting ready
here for the big VMAs I'm inside of
radio city where the show is taking
place i know i just posted a video on my
other channel but i just wanted to give
you guys another little view of
everything that I'm saying and I'm doing
because this is so much fun and I'm so
excited to share it all with you guys
because this is seriously just such an
awesome experience anyway i'm inside
Radio City here it is there's a naked
person right there that I want to show
you the actual event is all going on
over there and where I'm going to be
most of you guys know I am in here I'm
getting on top of the Radio City sign in
New York this is an amazing view of the
red carpet I can pretty much see
everything that's going on so right now
I'm walking out walking out so here we
go I'm gonna be walking out on the side
here's all my new best friends here we
go do not enter slippery but I'm
entering and tell you the secret Taylor
Swift fan forming right here right there
so you guys better watch and see that
because I got to see me
personal performance and it was amazing
so here we are he's beautiful Street the
wonderful red carpet and this is where
the tweets are going to be happening
right there oh there's my face so listen
you guys treat me these bubbles will
wait am I allowed to tell them my little
tell her the Internet can I tell them
what's going on okay okay I have to ask
because I'm never sure so basically you
guys need to tweet up a storm because
whoever you want to see you again here
there bubbles will get larger no one
knows this yet but that's what's
happened is I wanna tell you a choice
okay see ya my face is right there this
is the VMA thing everything is going on
I'm so excited to make sure at 8pm if
you guys are tweeting of the storm tweet
me tweet VMA treat MTV do whatever you
want to do it doesn't even matter I'm so
excited I will see you guys on your
little television that and yeah okay I
gotta go to teach what you're eating
don't forget street don't forget to
tweet me just keep yelling over there
let's go
yeah something I can't wait all right
here we go thank you